have you ever had a really bad
edible experience action uh
you know what you just kind of have to
go with it you just have to go with the
flow go with the wave
a good friend of mine who's sitting over
here and on the couch has had some
pretty interesting uh
um edible situations you know
it can get deep so you pretty much sit
you sink into wherever you're at
sink into the abyss you know it's like
it's like you drown in your own fluids
what about any have you ever had any
wild hallucinogenic experiences whether
it's mushrooms or
any like dmt or anything crazy yeah
plenty non always is always a crazy
situation what's the craziest
trip
there's been so many crazy ones but
it's like the the latest the latest one
the latest one is always the craziest
one is because you remember it the most
these things are almost like flashes in
time where you remember bits and pieces
but you cannot really explain it
right you know what i'm saying but there
are there are points where i can explain
what i'm trying to say
but not this one because i'm looking at
that barkley poster in the back
oh you see that charles barkley poster i
got hey look i got the
i got this i have that in my room yo man
y'all from phoenix so we got a represent
and then i got the old man in my room
right there
the bang 316 with vince on there that's
fire
yeah back to your uh mushroom trips has
have you ever
i've i just started to do mushrooms i
did mushrooms for the first time in
february
and it was like kind of therapeutic low
key was that something that like
do you do you find like therapeutic um
like do you find it to be therapeutic
whenever you do that [ __ ]
you have to eat more just keep eating
more
well how many did you eat did you eat a
little bit or a lot
i had a lot man i'd like a half of a
chocolate bar
yeah i don't know what that i i don't
know what goes into the chocolate bar so
what
what i'm what i suggest is you grab a
handful of mushrooms and stuff them in
your face
and then if you could actually talk to
me in an hour
eat some more i would like to hear about
it after you come home
so just go all just go all the way in
well
what's the fun and not you know you're
gonna [ __ ] have a little piece of
chocolate bar who even knows what you're
doing you might have just taken [ __ ]
you know who knows they might have put
shiitake mushrooms in there and you're
[ __ ]
eating shiitakes and you're feeling
funny what would be the advice you'd
give to anyone as far as like your
surroundings or
where you need to be at mentally before
you take take the all those shrooms to
the face because this is a lot about who
you're around and where you're at
unless you're performing so many factors
there's
so many it's very situational
since you know yeah it's like you have
to be [ __ ] bill belichick to get it
right
but for real at the end of the day you
have to you know
you'd like to be in nature but there's
been times where i've had some sicko
trips inside you know
that's what's happening we lost you know
there's been times where hours have been
lost
days have been lost you wake up you have
no idea what's going on
every time is different what i suggest
is you just try it all
just try it try it all see what works
for you
is there a drug that you've tried that
you would not suggest anyone try
yeah don't smoke dust don't do angel
dust
i don't know would you is that
considered angel dust i'm talking about
when you dip a cigarette or you dip a
blunt into that [ __ ] liquid
formaldehyde
yeah the [ __ ] man used to rap about dust
dip
yeah philly rappers like that [ __ ]
philly people that's a big
it was a big deal over there it's big in
like staten island and the bronx
stay away from the town yeah no it's
dust is no good
that was a bad experience for you yeah i
remember i hit the dust and i got the
flu for 14 days
[ __ ] yeah that's crazy
it was like [ __ ] 15 years ago but yo
that's crazy
yeah it was bad